so hello everybody i am sitting here
with christian hua for those who follow
the channel you
have probably seen my past interviews
with him on
jacqueline and some mcluhan as well and
the question of technicity the
the problem of technology and so he has
recently written
an article on marshall mcluhan and his
relationship differences to orthodoxy
because marshall mcluhan was a catholic
looking at the places of contact with
orthodoxy but also the differences and
also the possibility
within mcluhan of understanding how his
ideas connect to
symbolic world and to symbolic vision
and so i really thought it would be
a great opportunity to explore a little
more marshall mcluhan's work
see how it connects to symbolism and
also see how he was able to perceive
some of the things that we are seeing
happen around us in terms of technology
in terms of social
transformation and so i'm really looking
forward to this conversation
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so kristal maybe you can tell us a
little bit about your experience with
mcluhan i know the text that you
wrote for us was already presented at a
conference before
beforehand yeah the it was at the
the faith and works uh mcluhan faith and
works
conference in winnipeg saint paul
university in 2015
uh centered on
the religious dimension of
mclean's thought and activity
uh which has often been overlooked but
uh which has surfaced more in the to the
discussion since the publication of this
book by his son
eric who uh the medium and the live
reflections on
religion uh which is a collection of of
some of the
mcluhan's uh uh articles and and letters
uh pertaining to religion uh that it
but it appeared in 1999 i believe and
actually uh
and i won't uh dwell on it because james
cortines
already has in his uh in his
introduction to
his own reading of of my recent article
uh on mcl
on mcluhan for the blog so uh so
um
[Music]
well my
it was i guess among my first
uh direct engagements with mcluhan which
has informed my thought
for uh uh maybe decades probably since
the 1980s my thought on
on technique but is right uh so i i
i i i'm a bit of a dabbler in his
thought but
it's so it's so nourishing that even is
concentrating on a couple of articles
like we're
going to do it you know it it could you
could have
a whole seminar on that but
certain issues that stand out yeah in
ways that
will uh bring something to everyone's
thinking on symbol symbolism and so one
of the things that i find
fascinating with mcluhan and i think
that is really illuminating is the
manner in which he talks about
technique as an extension of the human
person as you know this is something
that i'm very fascinated with in terms
of the symbolism
of the garments of skin uh but mcluhan
really
emphasizes on the techn the techniques
of information
like media writing but then today with
television and
all the different media as extensions of
the psyche and so he really
he really tries to show how this
extension of the psyche is
different than just let's say physical
technologies like cars and all that so
maybe you can tell tell us a little bit
about his
his understanding of this extension of
the psyche
well it's more it it it's more down to
worse than that it's
it's extension of the nervous system see
because
uh technologies are extensions of
specific uh
organs uh as they appear
in human history you know the wheel is
an extension of
of the foot uh uh
well the house also is an extension of
the skin
this could go on for every medium you
can identify what does this
what does this extend in man's uh basic
physical equipment
and on the physical basis that well well
what
what okay so so the the basic the basic
uh
historical anthropological distinction
is between for him is between um
oral audio tactile cultures which is
sort of the baseline
of mankind for most of its of its
history
uh and and and visual dominated
uh uh uh
cultures that's structured by the
phonetic alphabet
that first appear uh when greeks adapt
the definition
uh uh uh uh alphabet
that is where where the the the
the the letters the the characters
correspond to
sound completely independent of of any
association
with their shape etc it's completely
arbitrary
but that gives a amazing flexibility in
in applications
to to classify things and order them
categorize them and that extends the
the reach of man but it also extends a
specific
sense which is uh the eyes uh uh
because uh in in normally at the at the
at the kind of uh baseline of of
of oral or uh most traditional cultures
common sense is uh again i guess
well there's a certain balance in the
sensorium in the uh
in the general uh distribution
of emphasis between the different uh
sensory
inputs uh but the the ones that that
that's
that are uh are are can can be said to
be
to give the tone for the whole thing is
more the hearing and and
touch which are related because uh
uh touch involves it's is also about
gaps you know you you when you touch
something and you don't merge with it
there's
there's there's a sensitive gap uh a
resident gap you would say
and so it's there's a continuity between
that and
and sound now
these sensations are are are kind of
they tend to be um non-specific they're
they're
low death and and low definition and and
they they surround you
and you can't you can't focus you can't
close your ears you know
you you hear things in a kind of
environmental way
so you you receive all of experience
kind of simultaneously
uh but in a sense that in a kind of
heterogeneous way uh
discontinuous way because you know
things will
will uh stand out in in very local ways
that that that uh
that that you can't you can't really
standardize
it it's it's just all jumbled together
and and
if there is an order to to emerge from
that is to a kind of a
a full-body attunement when you're when
you listen to
something and you attune yourself to to
the whole environment which will in this
context
you know the world culture will be the
whole tribal of communion
a communal environment where there's not
much of a distinction between
the individual and the group i mean this
distinction really
arises once you have uh
uh with with the phonetic alphabet you
have to um
you have to you have to uh to focus
while abstracting from
from context you have to to to kind of
like kind of
um you have to focus on the characters
and and and and and you you have a kind
of
meant let's say a mental image a very uh
schematic mental image a concept uh
so you you you have a kind of pinpoint
ability which you can also
which you can use to sort things in the
very sectoral
sectoral ways and and and uh
you so you can make the space
more continuous therefore you can have
citizens with equal rights in the
community called the police the city
uh uh which uh
and and have you know statues that are
very clear and realistic
et cetera it's very detailed because you
can sort of surround
visually uh what is given to you in
experience surveys
make it into a the sum of individual
parts you know
rather than a kind of whole body uh um
uh experience uh that that you you just
receive everything like a vision you
know a
division is uh it's kind of an acoustic
thing you know there's many
many apparent paradoxes like that but
you you receive things sort of uh
frontally wherever you you wherever you
you look in an acoustic
state because it's it's all kind of an
apparition out of out of nowhere like
out of a fog or
in in the dark whereas uh uh with
with the visual emphasis like the light
light is turned on and everything is
very
very clear very clear uh outline uh
no uh there's little few surprises there
was everything is more or less a
surprise in an acoustic space it's like
being
being in the fog you're sort of in in
wonder
or at whatever whatever happens you have
a more
a kind of magical or sacred relationship
if
if the lights are turned on and
everything is sort of uh
in its single place and not every uh not
in
ambivalent positions that could move
without uh without warning
uh it's more much more predictable so
you can
uh there's a control of the environment
is more possible there
so now now that is the the the the
classical greeks were the first to
pioneer that and to give out some of the
key uh uh uh
uh the the the the basic elements of
western
civilization but uh
things reverted to a more as more
scribal
and acoustic conditions in the late
roman empire
and born in in the near east etc
uh and in the middle ages these were
still
large largely still acoustic
culture even though they did they wrote
manuscripts now what changes
everything is the advent of print uh
well i've argued in my in my in my
article that actually the shift
to visual dominance and mcluhan
recognizes that
this at started the at the very around
the time of
the of the great schisms there was
already a kind of visual bias but it
came to a head with with interchangeable
uh print where you could sort of uh
[Music]
uh
uh this this i
this uh segmentation categorization
standardization
could have a kind of mass uh the
dimension that could you know others it
it heightened uh individual
uh identity and also non-local
collective identity like nations and
churches and sects
had to be defined in yes or no uh
in or out terms that were very sharp you
know so there had been multiplication of
set of sects
and of nation states uh rather than
broad universal jurisdiction where you
had a kind of
i guess a fractal relation between the
the
local unit and the universal one now you
had
to have the the standardized holes on
the national
or ideological scale now this started to
change
that was the gutenberg that's the
gutenberg galaxy
but that begins to be to to shift to the
but uh that's uh the
the title of uh mcluhan's famous 1962
book book that
one of the first that made him famous on
on this revolution caused by print
now uh that's that's followed that
something changes all together
uh with the with the new electric media
that begin with a telegraph
in the 1840s followed by radio
telephone uh
[Music]
major little television computers
these are electric media they're they're
a new environment and what they
emphasize is
what the organ they emphasize uh in
different ways
is that is uh is the central nervous
system
itself so it's your it's it's your
your neural wiring uh
both physical and cerebral that that is
outered
it it's it it's now centered on on
on this external wiring of of well
physical wires and now in a wireless way
a kind of
diffuse a global environment
which is what he meant by the global
village which has like the original
oral village acoustic properties where
again things like symbolism can find new
currency
in the way that they could not in the
highly uh
uh visual dominated
rationalistic methodical uh
and and quantitative oriented world of
the gutenberg galaxy
so there are new opportunities i guess
for
interesting symbolism and in it for him
it shows in
the the new receptivity of uh
contemporary man
for uh for uh tribal peoples oriental
religions
and even the oriental forms of
christianity you know that's what uh
my my article dealt with um
so these are the neo-acoustic traditions
the new tribal environment
that is created by the extensions of the
the the nervous system outside our body
so that we have now
actually ourself and our consciousness
is mostly outside of us
so i think to me one of the things that
makes it difficult for me to kind of
get into mcluhan is at first is
terminology
for example this oral versus visual
terms at first you wonder why
like you kind of wonder what he's saying
because like you said
that there are certain aspects which
which you could say is visual but he
considers more oral tactile
depending on on its kind of integrative
yeah uh
exactly so he ends up it ends up being
more about something which is
more kind of holistic this kind of
holistic experience versus something
which is focused yes and and segmented
and so if you understand it that way
then his terms start to make more sense
and you can see
how the progression that he that he
talks about in terms of the gutenberg
galaxy or the gutenberg explosion in
terms of this
uh you know this this hyper focus
this technical possibility of putting
knowledge in books
in a way that was not possible before
because in the world of the manuscript
even let's say in the world of the
ancient
uh text you would have a line of text so
people don't realize
that in ancient manuscripts there was no
separation between words
you would just have a line of text which
would cross the entire
page and the person reading because it
was low definition
as you as you mentioned the person
reading would have to buy his inner
knowledge
separate the words separate the
paragraph separate the sentences
and so with the gutenberg explosion
there is a need to create these clear
sentences paragraph punctuation all of
this becomes hyper
focused all of this is happening at the
same time there's a shift in thinking it
seems yeah
and individual access to standard text
it starts with the bible you know
therefore even the standardization the
absolute standardization of all text
becomes
necessary because we're printing them so
we need to
un until now there's some variability
which exists in the manuscripts because
of
transcription errors because of you know
different traditions of manuscripts
uh that are somewhat standardized but
then when
then we get to the printed text it has
to be standardized and dialed in
now you have to standardize national
languages that are
uh that are uh uh uniform within certain
certain boundaries and that that that
applies to
all of society it has to be uh uh
uniform so that that there's
interoperability between
the the the the all the all the agencies
the manifestation of these new
extensions
of man they don't function if they don't
have standardization
on a certain territory and now all that
is is is offended when it becomes
electorate because there's the the the
the boundaries are
are fuzzy things that happen you know
and on on
on on more and more of a global well of
course
the world had been globalized by
capitalism explorations
were like already under gutenberg but it
it happens
at uh at the less territorial and more
directly experiential level through the
media
themselves uh starting with the
telegraph radio etc
television and our computers so that
that becomes the primary reality
actually
uh uh of how we experience even
ourselves you know to
to these reflections of these extensions
uh well you know
just look at smartphones it's they've
become a new
organ that i've had for a dozen years
and our self our very identity is
complete is centered in it now
if someone loses their phone they lose
their face the public face and we come
back that's why we come back
to uh and an and and
shame culture as opposed to a a guild
culture which was
a hallmark of uh more of uh
uh of the gutenberg galaxy and
alphabetics
we come back to oral conditions what the
worst thing that can happen to you is
uh is to lose faith to be canceled to
not not have
a good reputation in your in your
immediate community to be shunned by
your village which is now the global
village
cancel culture yeah cancer culture is
definitely part of it we also notice
in the in the age of the cell phone in
the age of uh
of the internet especially we can see
the breakdown
of grammar there's a deliberate
breakdown of grammar in order to
manifest
tribal affiliation you can see that in
meme culture
where they will on purpose if someone
who can spell the world
word will on purpose misspell words in
order to
to create a sense of tribal uh tribal
group
uh and so mcluhan even already
in the 1960s was seeing this
re-tribalization which he talks about
through electric media of course he
didn't have the internet at the time but
he was definitely
foreseeing something like the internet
um in the uh
in the in the playboy article which he
gave he really does talk about
you know this this inter connectivity
and
this this exteriorization
and and how it's going to lead to
re-tribalization what's fascinating
about his
interpretation is that he he was
predicting
you know he was predicting a a return to
ethnic uh conflict a return to
uh tribal conflict in terms of nations
and everything
one of the things i don't know if he
first saw was rather what
uh you know what people are talking
about right now in terms of mimetic
tribes which is that we we have broken
down into tribes but these tribes are
these strange ideological tribes which
are not centered in space
and so you have online tribes which
which connect to each other
and these online and they're not related
to your local
they're not spatial they're not special
they're they're entirely in this
this new the the subtle dimension
uh uh of an outward uh psyche of an
outer wiring a
an outer brain with an outer collective
planetary brain yeah that's what they
are
uh and uh you just mentioned the the the
the you know mccoon article in people we
should we should
i guess specify what we're talking about
this this interview is based
aside from our own article on two uh
mcluhan's two contributions to to
playboy magazine which are actually
probably the best introduction to his to
start this is famous
a very long interview in the
the the april 16 1969 issue
uh which is very well known included in
anthologies like this one
the essential mcluhan there's also a
less known uh
uh article by him uh april uh
19 uh no december 1968 which we
also read the uh in preparation of this
interview so uh
but the the the uh so the mcluhan
interview
in playboy and is one of the he
didn't like interview he would he would
just sort of uh ramble out
uh you know spin out his ideas but he
didn't like the interview format because
it would pin him down you know
uh
yeah you can turn it off and then yeah
i'll cut that out don't worry well i
think it's it's pretty good
my point yeah exactly
i feel like like i've cut a limb yeah
you cut it off and thrown his phone away
um but well throw out your eye if it
offends you
and you know uh if it if
if it causes you to sin yeah and and
probably
it's something that that that i think in
his more sober
super new sober moods he might
countenance you know
and uh i like to cut that off
yeah and of course to him with electric
conditions
the deal is uh uh an ear for an eye you
know
i'm here for now yeah he mentioned that
in his article so
so mclean saw the this re-tribalization
one of the things that i i struggle with
or one of the things that i'm
i see that he talks about but i'm not
sure i don't know how clearly he saw it
or if he was just kind of
he seemed to have some weird kind of
prophetic capacity is he talks about
re-tribalization he talks about the
breakdown
this return to these tribal identities
you could say
this is something that i noticed as well
the return of identity
in different manners is it seems to be
coming back
uh you know in some scary and some more
interesting ways
but then he also talks about how that
will lead or that
is also part of this global village and
so on the one hand you have a
re-tribalization
but on the other hand you have what he
talks about in terms of
moving towards a kind of unifying
world or a unified world under this new
global consciousness or this
this conscience that will rise above the
the yeah
well it's not it's less uh it's less
under or over but that's
as you know it's it's
well uh yes it's it's
it's hard to follow him there because i
mean because there's these two aspects
tribalization
and and global consciousness so the
tribal aspect that
what he describes in 1969 is that there
too is
this amazing resonance he talks about
the the the
the the the the impending civil war of
the united states that will not
will not survive long as a unified
country will will break up into many
states along racial and regional
lines the problem is that
if i don't know if he would have seen
that what he's suggesting
has become even more complicated through
this mimetic
tribe and so it's it's almost now
impossible to think of the united states
breaking down in regional that's it
yeah because because now it's it's all
through the system
you have these these these different
groups that are set up and these tribes
are entirely online really
yeah they don't have much of a
geographic
space unless unless people come out and
start burning buildings as we've seen
as we saw this year it's like the
conflict is all
is emerging is popping out into the into
the real world
right now but it starts online exactly
it all starts basically
yes it is yeah you're totally right it's
and canceled culture is is based online
um and so this is really i mean this is
the place where i struggle although it's
like i struggle to understand him
because he talks about a return to
memetic or he doesn't use dominic but a
return to tribalism
a a less individualized society
a society which is more based on group
affiliation
uh but then he also talks about this
kind of desire for global
consciousness and i see it to me it
doesn't make sense but i see it around
me
everywhere that is the narrative that is
being proposed to us
in terms of global culture is exactly
that
right yeah it is a kind of it's a kind
of
idea of of of like
a diversity but at the same time
everybody
is in the same global culture
there's an element of that that is not
being ideological here no
from it far from it you know his own
stance really
basically he'd like to be a hobbit you
know that that's
he'd like to be in a constant small
scale uh
craft based semi-scribal culture that
didn't really
change but he has to deal with the the
culture in which he's born
and he tries not to have value judgments
about it so he's just describing it and
yet
so it sort of plays with what it could
become it could be something not that
bad
something actually like a village except
on a different scale but which could
also be a nightmare you know
so well one of the most astounding two
images that he proposes in the same
interview
in this paper interviews that on the one
hand he moves
at first he's talking about media but
then he moves in a weird mystical space
where he talks about what's coming as
replacing or being analogous to the
to the the body of christ in the church
but at a global scale and so there's a
there's a strange move towards this
image but then he also says
maybe it could also be the antichrist
yeah and so and so i'm wondering if he
and other places if you've seen him talk
about this or what he'd what would
differentiate that and if not what you
think would differentiate the two
so i've been thinking about about that
because it's
rarely clear i mean for every
instance where he seems to to
to lean in one direction you can find
another another where where
he leans the other and that happens in
this very within a couple of pages in
this playboy interview that's what
happens
uh you know it could it it it could
fulfill the diet on not
on a galactic scale you know it's kind
of uh
i mean it's it's well it's transhumanist
territory
really you know it's uh uh
a kind of uh uh a global consciousness
that would have shifted
uh with that with no
no distinction between the individual
and the collective and would expand
throughout the the universe
and reshape it in a kind of uh artistic
way it would sort of refashion itself
in an artistic way uh well that is
that's his uh
optimistic um hypothesis um
uh well i i want to come back first
to the to the the the tension with the
how can that happen
at the same time as the as the
re-tribalization
uh uh
well what's in common is that in both
the tribal and the global level the
individual sort of merges back
into into the or more oral uh
collective uh i i
i i
guess he he he suggested
he suggested since it's the same
electronic elements even these tribal
conflicts are
well they could settle well he's talking
in 1969 it could settle into
some uh some some kind of
uh accepted diversity where where every
tribe would appreciate the other one as
a tribe
within this common element well he
doesn't
uh i mean other places he says well the
global village is not about you know
peace and harmony
it means that that that you're you're
always too close for comfort and looking
over your shoulder and thinking that
that someone might have cursed you and
said you have the evil lie
you know and and you're almost
on the edge of being at each other's
throat and and
so it's not a it's not a cozy place so
you know
so he always but his way of thinking is
by sending out probes you know
by in a sense uh troy literally
literally try it throwing out ideas into
this new environment and see what sticks
you know playing playing with them and
see what
how what echo will come back see what uh
uh saw some
different probes different instances of
his of his speculations give different
results at different times so they're
all possibilities to
to entertain but but i guess
at that that at that particular fireside
chat he was
was in a relatively good mood so he
tried to entertain the more positive
uh the positive side of things where he
thought that maybe
the creativity that he drew personally
from it from his
is his literate culture and then the
avant-garde figures
in in in in in in
in western literature that that sort of
uh foresaw uh the the changes ahead
maybe if if that the creativity of a
choice or a pound or an elliot it may be
it could be shifted
to the to the to the global uh
uh uh electric uh neo
uh acoustic uh uh environment which the
the the the uh uh they foreshadowed in
in
in their work so that's an optimistic
hypothesis but
but what my
my perception of that is you you can't
have creativity
uh on a kind of uh for for
a collective brain on the on on on the
planet on the scale of a planet you have
to have
uh uh embodiment in a finite self that
has to
to find its ways around the the the
the the different dimensions of it of
its finitude in in space and time
and and the uh
a kind of uh uh
[Music]
aesthetic and spiritual wonder at its
own contingency trying to
renegotiate uh the the the different
parameters of its
of its embodied of of embodied existence
every moment it's something that artists
do by feeling out
the environments is seeing how things
could be
experiencing and enacting how things
could be
reconfigured how the connections could
be made with these different
directions of the self i don't see this
being so
up uploaded to a collective
artificial intelligence uh
it would just go on you know like like a
borg or whatever you know
you know that that's that i mean how
else do you do yeah
imagine something spreading like that to
the to the earth and beyond you know
yeah reminds me it reminds me you know
of uh
the projected ending of
june you know where where there's
there's a kind of
uh uh a a a collective
awakening well uh the the messiah paul
muad dibs skill but everyone says i am
paul i'm paul and paul and the whole
planet so start to move to the universe
to bring in a collective enlightenment
to the whole universe of this collective
consciousness it's a kind of 60s
yeah it's like an electric these things
you know it doesn't age well
but i think that there's something about
his apocalypticism which is
interesting in the sense that there you
know you see
in the christian tradition you'll see
this notion
of the two versions of the last judgment
christ talks about how
the wheats and the tares are growing
together and
that it's only at the end that we'll be
able to separate the wheat from the
tears
and so i think that maybe his intuition
was something like that where he was
he was seeing that in this increase
in technicity that it that there's
extreme danger and extreme extreme uh
danger of falsification
of uh of chaos of pride but at the same
time
he can't completely discount it he sees
there's also positive in it and is
different
he was struggling to separate the two
but it's it's a
it's a it's a strange thing because even
in terms of the
difference between christ and antichrist
everybody thinks that
they'll be the one who who can tell the
difference uh
but it's it's very different it's very
difficult to know
you know that the difference between
let's say uh an example in scripture the
difference between
judas telling christ that they should
use the money to help the poor
and christ telling us to help the poor
yeah and so what is the difference
there is a difference between the two
but i think that it's easy to be seduced
by
by you know by one or the other that's
it's easy to be seduced by the
falsification and
in terms of i think that in i wonder
in terms of where we're seeing it go now
in terms of
the little versions of what he's talking
about like something like facebook
or or twitter or even google itself
we can really perceive the dark
aspects of this kind of global
consciousness or this
this this like global brain we can see
it taking form in front of us
and it doesn't it doesn't necessarily
look pretty because it is
too it too easily becomes a frame
that can be manipulated and once we're
connected to it
then that manipulation becomes 1984
style
the inevitability of of of reality like
that first page of google
the first page of google search has
become the new frame
of many people's perception except
there's no big brother in this
constellation
no no one no one's in particular is is
is is ordering all of this you know and
anyone who does
is itself a a a a
a dispensable organ of that
configuration which has
a mind of its own you know our most our
mind is mostly
already offloaded up there and
to come back to the contrast of
tribalization and globalization well
what we're experiencing now is both at
once
tribalization heightens our fascination
our our absorption
and migration into the global medium
that's where our being
is and the more we're excited about
tribal conflict the more we we
are the the the the global uh
consciousness so uh uh
and so sorry for those who think that
that that you know uh
uh vaccines or viruses or or or whatever
are going to invade your body from
outside you're already inside
the beast i like to say we're already uh
intestinal flora in the belly of the
beast yeah that you have to
deal with that it's not coming from
outside you're already being digested
you're part of its metabolism so what do
we do with that yeah
but would you like one of the ways to
understand it this is a way that it's
going to scare people when i say it but
to me a way of understanding it has to
do with
talking about the traditions in enoch
right this this notion of the fallen
angel
or this notion of the principality which
falls into
the world and brings about the
mechanical world or the
metallurgic world that is there before
the flood
you know and so when we say that there's
nothing let's say controlling it
uh to me all bodies need principalities
okay
and so i can't i to let's say nobody in
particular
right but there are to me there has to
be some principalities that are
that are using this as a as a body and
so i don't i don't necessarily
and i don't want to free i don't want
people to be freaked out like i'm
thinking
but i think that there's an
inevitability and because
the system like because the systems are
geared towards our
passions let's say it's clear that
facebook and twitter use
our irascible passions to stay alive
that's how they they they feed on our
our our our conflict uh
it matters uh not one with
which which side you're on in the
culture wars the the deeper you're in
well
on whatever side the deeper you you you
you're within the one
subject that that is uh
of this this this whole thing that you
think you're fighting you know yeah
yeah well there has been there has been
a let's say i think there has been some
efforts
on part of some of the media texts to
take sides
but every time they really do take a
side they
they in the end end up weakening their
own beast
because like you said it feeds off
conflict if you say
we're going to remove extremes from this
side
then they're they're they're weakening
themselves
like zuckerberg did a few days back by
while saying well you know the new
documentary on
uh on social media uh you know it is
uh uh we're we're starting to
to to deal with with content so so it is
it's going to
be under control but that's not the
point that's the basic mcluhan point
doesn't the content
is not the issue it's the medium that's
that's where the subject
your consciousness is it doesn't matter
what what are
wha what what
the particular uh motif emerges
in in that in that element it's the
element itself
and how how do you even perceive this
element you know
like like he liked it uh uh often said
uh
you know we we're we're not sure who
discovered water but we're pretty sure
it wasn't a fish
you know you need a counter environment
like him he could perceive what was
happening because
well as a literate man he was
outside the uh uh
electric environment to some degree but
unlike other illiterate man of his of
his day
he could also he could not he could not
pretend that his his familiar categories
uh of of of of of written texts you know
shielded him
from from the outside world of
advertisement and and
the actual life of the contents of the
consciousness of
the student not the contents but the the
the the
the fabric you know of the human mind as
it existed
uh in in the in in the the the young man
she faced as
as a professor see so uh it's not a
matter of the of the contest but
it's the the medium itself the the the
electric
uh uh this electric psyche that we have
and
uh i might get into scary territory too
but i like to think of it in terms of an
aggregor
which is a term from from occultism
about a kind of emergent collective
being that that comes from an an
entitlement and meshing
uh uh uh of the of of i guess of
different intentions intentionalities
different consciousness
that become that become a mind of their
own so
a civilization or a religion could be a
negro gore or
but these things you know they're
they're
it's it's uh is it's a psychic entity
that that exists
on its own well agrigore means from the
from the herd you know
it's something constituted from it's a
herd mind that exists
independently of its individual
constituents yeah
so that that thing that we're
uh uh uh
the drifting on or part of it has a mind
of its own and it and it
probably has some some kind of uh of
uh uh of weird intentionality that we
can't
fathom you know it's a psychic entity
that happens to have an electric body
you know
yeah but that's where i that's where to
me at least under
seeing this happen and like you said
noticing it and noticing
uh that its intention is beyond the
individual intentions of those involved
and you can see it
like you can you can see that zuckerberg
and uh
what's his name uh the ceo of twitter
they're they're they can't control their
monster anymore they're
it's completely out of control for them
and they keep saying they'll do it
but they can't and so you can notice
that these things
have a will of their own based on the
very
on the patterns that were set up you
know in the beginning as they were
coming to life and this is where to me
i i it helps me to understand the idea
of fallen angels like it really helps me
to understand
what fallen angels can mean how these
how principalities
fall can fall into into aggregate bodies
and start to manifest patterns which are
are disjuncted they're they're real and
but they're
they're they're destructive in the sense
that they that they're feeding
on their they're feeding on each other
and they're they're
not let's say they're feeding on the
energy of the people almost like a weird
parasite
uh but it's not a parasite because it's
we are the ones who are giving it its
energy and for it to exist
and because it's not individuated it's
kind of unreal unvulnerable you know you
can't pin it down and say oh if we
pin it if if we if we if we strike it
there no it won't stay there it's so
diffused you know yeah
well it's viral you know yeah
you know um but
and and so it to me it's very it's very
fascinating to
to see that mcluhan seems to have had
even before the internet
seems to have had a intuition of how
this was
kind of moving where it was going but in
in order to not be too negative i think
one of the things you explore
in the article and one of the things i
want to explore with you is
because it is a breakdown of this
gutenberg galaxy
because this new electric world this new
electro
electric acoustic world of tribalism
there is in that nonetheless an opening
to talk about a more symbolic
vision a more connected vision and a
more
even within the chaos yeah to introduce
a more
kind of holistic coherent vision of the
world but you're living proof of
it we are you know we you know we we're
also
uh you know uh uh psychic projections
are
already existing in that element and yet
we point
to something else uh maybe not outside
but certainly
inside each uh still existing embodied
subjects see
uh caught up as we are in in in this
psychic
flood uh so
it's an element that is conducive to
symbolism as well as con confusion and
also to the confusion of symbolism
uh so uh uh discernment
and and and and and and and attempts
at at uh uh a at an
embodied focus such as what uh
uh a spiritual or ritual practice can
can provide
is of the essence here if we want to to
retain
our humanity and and and and maybe
recover
uh uh and an integrity of a different
kind than just uh going and merging with
the the the the milestone
uh of of the electric beast
this would i mean a few decades ago if
you would
refer to the divine which what what
would you show you would show
a
uh michelangelo 16 chapel you know uh a
piece of meat handling and
hanging in mid-air and and and gesturing
to another piece of meat
but in a wonderfully realistic detail
and that would be
it's the idea of the divine that each
atheists still propagate you know that
when they think of
religion oh it's the it's what yeah that
well
people are generally spiritual now they
they hardly bother with that
what what they know to be spiritual is
is an icon
a mandala something from a a an archaic
a culture
a tribal culture a a well and a non-good
gutenberg culture even a christian one
yeah and
that's because of the re-balancing of
the censorium that's happened
thanks to the breakdown of the gutenberg
galaxy under the impact of the marconi
constellation
uh that is now
coming to its full flowering uh uh
uh with with with the uh are uploading
in a in a global instantaneous uh
electro electronic and cybernetic
environment see
so uh yes even even as as
you know uh tiny microbes in the belly
of the beast
we're still an element of we can still
regain some we can ourselves become the
parasites
of that larger very ambiguous
being no but i agree i think that this
is one of the reasons why i talk about
what i call the double inversion
or you know this the the fool at the end
which turns things back
which is that in the world that is in
the world of the
the beast like when the the let's say
this beast has taken over you know those
that
constitute some form of normal hierarchy
appear as a parasite that that
finds some food actually in the belly of
the beast to
point people back towards the and and
use i it's like that's why one of the
reasons why i talk about
monsters and peripheral things is
because
i can i i can because that's where we
that's what we're in we're in this weird
agora of
of disparate elements which are
nonetheless connected together in a
kind of chaotic manner and manifest will
you know
that in that there's food to point
back towards a kind of normal kind of
normal order which also includes the
monsters on the edge and includes you
know the leviathan
which which is this this uh this the
beast that that are on the edge
um and so i think that there's i think
that there's hope maybe not for
every everything but there's hope at
least for a remainder or
a small arc that can float inside the
digestive tract of the beast
yeah but we have to be a sort of
nimble you know well of course
yeah well mcluhan's you know classic
simile for the situation in which it
you know it's was the the the senate
dude the maelstrom by
by guerrero you know where this this
this guy is is in a shipwreck
his ship is is you know he's floating
around
the debris of his ship are are circling
in this huge
uh whirlpool that's emerging the ocean
and falling into this
black hole and but so he sees the end
approaching with every turn every
revolution of of the
uh of the mindless spin and yet he
observes among the debris some that
that are floating well some some
uh faster with the current some slower
some
actually even opposite the current he
realizes that there are some counter
currents there
so he manages i believe to to swim to
one that that
flows in the opposite direction that
goes up that was not down but
uh up to the to the to the to the to to
to the sea and beyond the pull
of the milestone and that that was
mcluhan's uh wager you know
uh so if we understand the medium that
we're uh
immersed in that that's sucking us uh us
into
a a black hole imploding a bit before us
uh we have to learn to swim it and to
navigate the currents and cur
counter currents and we first have to to
observe it but not necessarily in the
visual way we have to feel our way
through it in a sense
uh or actually bring to bear all our our
senses
uh uh uh including
the the the distinct sense that that
that uh
mcluhan saw in faith itself he described
it
it describes faith uh
catholic faith in his in his terms uh as
something completely different from what
people understand it's it's not a
concept in the sense of a belief or a
trust etc
it's a percept
a sense and sensibility to so to certain
resonant
harmonies between between uh
realities visible and invisible uh that
that that are like a sixth uh sense that
that
structures the the interplay of the of
the five other ones the spiritual sense
the percept
uh which is not based on on distance but
when but
not on incomplete immersion either but
but but in the uh
awareness of the interplay and the
resonance between different levels
different currents etc
so uh that's what we need to
to develop and you know uh uh
certain spiritual disciplines can are
probably the best bet
to to navigate that as as long as we're
not
too stuck in their form and we can also
bring discernment to
just the element and that we're immersed
in the
the residents resonance among the among
its celtic
debris the flotsam of of uh
surrounding us see there are
things that we can use to build a raft
and maybe guide it
to the surface all right well i think
that
on that note of hope it's probably a
good place
to finish our conversation uh and so i i
just want to i want to thank you for
this
this moment i hope that everybody this
has been useful
to kind of begin or to think about uh
this exploration mcluhan who was a
strange
in a way strange modern prophet who
perceived what was happening
and i think that i think it's now your
call for us to be aware
of where we are not be naive about the
environment in which we
are living so that we can navigate it as
best we can
so that we can change the depth into
something better yeah so thanks for your
time
thank you i hope you enjoyed this
discussion on marshall mcluhan as you
might know
the symbolic world is not just these
videos but it's also a blog
there is also a podcast and there's also
a facebook group where people discuss
all these different ideas on symbolism
so make sure to check that out there is
also
a clips channel which breaks apart some
of my ideas into smaller
shareable clips and because of some of
the subjects we're talking about youtube
is
not favorable to us and so make sure to
subscribe and to share these videos
on your own so that we can get these
ideas out there
for those who are watching this that's
just coming out teespring is offering
a full sale until the end of the weekend
and so you can use the
code word hayride to get 10 off
symbolic world merchandise it's a good
time to buy all those great christmas
gifts
for lovers of symbolism and so thanks
everybody for your support and for your
time and i will talk to you very soon
you